[Applaudissements]
pas évident de passer après ça
alors bonsoir à tous j'ai l'honneur et
le grand privilège d'être le dernier
talk de ce thé xx est la première chose
que j'aimerais vous dire c'est que un
grand m10 est le meilleur pour la fin
je n'y ai jamais cru donc je m'appelle
grégoire et j'ai un métier un peu
particulier qui fait que mon père ou ma
copine ou mes beaux parents ont du mal à
expliquer aux autres et que c'est un peu
gênant
en fait mon métier ces hackers
professionnels
vous imaginez une plaque ses écrits
pirates informatiques à la place des
avocats ou médecins une pensée bon père
qui m'a payé des études mais en fait
j'aimerais bien qu'on reparte de ce
qu'est un vrai à coeur d'un point de vue
purement sémantique il ya une mauvaise
traduction départ en fait un hacker
c'est avant tout est désolé de vous
décevoir pour les plus talentueux et les
plus beaux d'entre vous vous êtes dans
le noir ça c'est facile de dire ça c'est
avant tout un bidouilleur en fait on
n'est pas des pirates informatiques le
pirate informatique c'est le cracker ce
qui est un autre mot en anglais
on est des bidouilleurs c'est à dire que
là où une personne normale sera sur une
belle route goudronnée en train de
marcher dans la foule a pas réduit le
hacker lui cours dans la forêt avec sa
machette
parfois ça va plus vite parfois non
surtout quand vous avez pas de carte et
ce qui se passe c'est que ce hacker il
peut résider en chacun d'entre nous là
où une personne normale ne va voir
qu'une opportunité qu une tristesse
pardon une tristesse dans un élément
dans un décès le hacker lui avoir une
opportunité une résilience
là où une personne normale de m'avoir
que un acte banal aller à la selle
le hacker lui va voir qu'avec cet acte
banal on peut changer les choses on peut
aller mieux mais alors vous allez me
dire ça à l'air génial d'être un hacker
mais comment devient ton à coeur et bien
c'est pas compliqué il faut seulement
quatre étapes
est ce que vous voyez la vidéo où vous
pouvez gagner 3000 euros facilement en
suivant des méthodes vous savez la pop
up sur les sites pornographiques
je dis cela je n'ai jamais arrêté de
sites pornographiques j'ai eu des
informations on a tous un collègue qui
peut nous raconte vous voulez devenir ce
hacker écrit comme ça en blanc sur une
diapositive noir avec une police bien
particulière combat le nom de la police
tout est dans le détail la première
chose à faire c'est de prendre
conscience des règles si vous n'avez pas
conscience des règles
vous n'avez aucun moyen de les
contourner et pour cela il faut revenir
sur un point particulier c'est comment
naissent les règles prenons un petit
garçon comme j'en ai beaucoup rencontrés
ils sont pas tous comme lui mais il y en
a quand même beaucoup
on va l'appeler cédric pourquoi parce
que personne dans mon entourage proche
ne s'appelle cédric le choix des prénoms
et stratégiques on y reviendra tout à
l'heure
donc la conscience cédric le problème
qu'il a c'est que quand il est petit il
pose des questions il dit papa papa
pourquoi je peux pas sauter dans les
flaques d'eau visualiser votre enfant
bien l'habiller avec ses baskets
blanches vous avez acheté en soldes à la
halle aux chaussures
ceci est un placement de produit sauter
dans une flaque et vous dis mais
pourquoi pourquoi je dois rentrer à 21h
quand vous parlez le soir parce que ce
qui vous fait chier en fait mais vous
savez quand vous êtes discussions entre
adultes et que l'enfant pense qu'il peut
apporter quelque chose au débat alors qu
en fait pas du tout j'ai cru ça encore
et je crois encore aujourd'hui ces
problématiques
en ce qui me concerne je n'ai jamais
arrêté ils demandent toujours pourquoi
et petit à petit ils arrêtent de
demander pourquoi il se met à assimiler
les règles ils pensent que travailler
tard c'est normal ils pensent qu'il faut
bien travailler à l'école
toute série qui finit par à 6 noeuds par
ne même plus voir
eh bien je vais vous conter l'histoire
du petit grégoire et là vous comprenez
que le nom du petit garçon n'a peut-être
pas été choisie au hasard
souvenez vous je m'appelle aussi
grégoire il a sans doute quelque chose à
jouer ici intéressant n'est-ce pas
tout à l'heure on a dit grigor lève
cette blague ça passera pas je le dis au
pire je ferais celle là après peut-être
que ça passera mais elle passe pas non
plus j'ai pas d'idée on continue donc
petit grégoire petit grégoire est aussi
demande pourquoi pourquoi pourquoi
pourquoi mais il continue un peu plus
tard et vous voyez lui quand il arrive
au lycée au collège
peut-être un petit peu avant au collège
il ne comprend il ne voit pas les règles
il ne les assimile pas là où le petit
cédric les assimiler progressivement et
finissez par le faire partie de son
quotidien
le petit grégoire lui ne les assimile
pas ce qui fait que la première fois
qu'il drague une fille et ma copine me
regarde mais il y en a eu un avant toit
je te promets mon arrière et beau parent
ou tu regardes avec elle du coup c'est
vachement délicat on voulait se marier
on est pas encore bref passons basson
basson
on enchaîne on enchaîne en charge alors
t'as que dix minutes un premier gérer
plus vite sur la fin du coup ce qui se
passe c'est que lui le petit grégoire ou
là où les autres assimilés règle il ne
les assimile pas ce qui fait que il va
se prendre des murs il va y arriver
c'est draguer une fille veulent envoyer
10 15 testo voit ce qu'il se dit elle ne
répond pas c'est qu'elle n'a pas eu mon
message du coup il lui envoie des textos
puis il la rappelle
puis il va la voir le gîte a pas vu mais
douce textos et mes quatre appels c'est
bizarre je pense que tu as devrait avoir
un problème avec ton forfait
oui c'est un maire quitte à confisquer
son téléphone cette scène s'est vraiment
passé
ultra malesan l'amérique dire penser ça
me fait une petite douleur ça veut dire
la thérapie ce tedx donc je disais on
est parti pour avec un bon 15 minutes je
vais plus vite je pus vite veut plus
vite ils m'ont dit grégoire va vite va
vite est là il parle il parle il parle
il parle et parle on n'est pas bien donc
là donc ils n'assimile pas l'air etc ce
qui fait qu'il les a dans la douleur il
les ressent au plus profond de lui même
si fait que toutes ces règles il les
matérialisent de façon très précise
ce qui fait qu'aujourd'hui il peut aider
les gens à matérialiser ses règles mais
alors vous comment est ce que vous
faites pour prendre conscience de ces
règles eh ben il ya deux moyens
principaux le premier moyen c'est de
vous confronter comme on disait tout à
l'heure à d'autres cultures
parce que les autres cultures n'ont pas
les mêmes règles allaient essayé de
draguer aux états unis ce que je n'ai
jamais fais parce que je ne parle pas
anglais mais essayer de faire ça vous
verrez que les méthodes sont
complètement différentes
essayez de sortir de votre cercle
vous êtes à grenoble vous devez aller
faire des footings tous les soirs dans
la montagne c'est comme ça vous êtes
apparaît vous devez travailler tous les
soirs jusqu'à 22h et faire un brunch le
dimanche c'est comme ça fait rencontrer
un grenoblois un parisien à lyon il se
passe des trucs de fou et moi je vous
conseille pour prendre conscience des
règles de sortir de cette zone est
d'aller voir des gens qui culturellement
sont différents de vous et la deuxième
chose c'est plus difficile c'est
d'écouter l'enfant qui est en chacun
nous cet enfant qui vous dit pourquoi
de l'écouté la deuxième étape il ya
quatre étapes lors que j'allais plus
vite c'est comprendre l'essence de la
règle le fondement de la règle pourquoi
est ce que cette règle existe et ça
c'est absolument primordiale pour
pouvoir la contourner
je vous prends un exemple il faut bien
travailler à l'école
pourquoi est-ce qu'il faut bien
travailler mais en fait il faut bien
travailler pendant une bonne note
ça ne sert à rien de bien travailler si
vous travaillez bien que vous n'avez pas
des bonnes notes ça ne fonctionne pas
très bien donc il faut bien travailler
pour avoir une bonne note
on pourra aller plus loin tout à l'heure
mais entre la 16e et la 18e minute
il faut bien travailler mais en fait
pour avoir une bonne note
il ya une autre méthode en fait vous
travaillez bien pour faire croire que
vous maîtrisez votre sujet comme le talk
d'avant qui étaient parfaitement
maîtrisés
ça c'était pas moi à l'école typiquement
et ensuite vous rendez une copie qui
vous permet d'avoir une bonne note mais
vous pouvez aussi faire autre chose
c'est faire croire que vous maîtrisez
bien votre sujet vous enlevez la case
bien travailler et vous fait croire que
vous maîtrisez votre sujet c'est ce que
j'ai fait en anglais pour le bac
d'anglais où j'ai une note beaucoup trop
élevé pour mon niveau où j'ai appris
bêtement des phrases et des mots de
vocabulaire très peu en quelques jours
quelques soirées et on faisait tout
recaler pour faire voir que je
maîtrisait parfaitement la grammaire et
le vocabulaire
ce qui fait que j'ai une excellente note
et que j'ai un niveau d'anglais qui
aujourd'hui totalement déplorable
comme je disais tout à l'heure la
troisième chose c'est l'impact
quel va être l'impact du fait de
contourner cette règle sur votre vie
vous devez faire peser le pour et le
contre
un autre exemple à 20 ans je me suis dit
je veux devenir entrepreneur comme mon
papa
une originalité sans faille le hacker
qui sommeil en moins
société une psychothérapie sait rigoler
un peu
ça me rend difficile surtout qu'il est
présent dans la pièce est bien quand
vous voulez devient entrepreneur vous
dites les études ne servent à rien parce
que si on fait des études et ce qu'on
dit tout à l'heure on travaille bien
pour de bonnes notes pour avoir un beau
diplôme pour avoir un travail mais si
vous sortez complètement du cadre vous
dit en fait peut-être que je n'ai pas
besoin de faire des études pour devenir
entrepreneur je peux me lancer à la
steve jobs à la bill gates bon après les
mecs ont arrêté entre la dernière année
de harvard certains donc c'est sûr que
ça aide quand même ils ont quand même
fait des trucs avant mais on va oublier
ce stade là vous vous dites je peux
arrêter mes études
et là vous dites bénéfices risques
bénéfices
un impact sur votre vie vous allez
peut-être gagné 5 ans risque vous ne
pourrez jamais revenir en arrière jamais
quand vous avez du mal à tenir sur une
chaise vous savez que si vous arrêtez un
an deux ans vous ne pourrez jamais
revenir à l'école et peut-être que tout
va toute votre vie on va vous reprocher
de ne pas avoir fait d'études
il ya des gens qui osent se lancer moi
je n'ai pas osé clairement j'ai décidé
que cet impact et des trois négatifs et
j'ai fini mes études de droit
comme j'aime bien la règle la dernière
chose c'est l'audace l'audace c'est ce
qui fait que vous allez vraiment
réveillé le hacker qui sommeille en vous
que cette personne va sortir je vous
prends l'exemple vous avez un projet
entrepreneurial vous voulez changer les
choses mais ils vous font un million
d'euros 2 millions d'euros ou peut-être
deux trois quatre 4 ans de travail avant
de lancer votre projet il y a des moyens
de hacker le système par exemple vous
pouvez faire comme si votre offre existe
et la mettre sur un site internet m des
faux témoignages de la fosse presse
faire comme si le produit existe et
envoyer du trafic dessus c'est ce que je
fais tous les jours mais qui sont
experts en trou noir moi je suis expert
en facebook est un tout petit peu moins
classe mais on s'en sort est ce que vous
pouvez faire c'est que ce trafic là vous
pouvez analyser si oui ou non les
personnes sont intéressées par votre
produit et si les personnes sont
intéressés vous pouvez y aller
ce qui veut dire que n'importe quelle
personne ici qui a un projet qu'il
faille un an deux ans trois ans de
travail qui fasse plusieurs dizaines de
milliers d'euros il n'a aucune excuse
pour ne pas se lancer pour ne pas tester
il a aucune raison de rester assis sur
sa chaise il ya
aucune raison il ya aucun risque il ya
juste 2 3 4 10 jours de perdus dans
votre vie c'est rien eh bien ça malgré
qu'on l'enseigne qu'on le dise à des
entrepreneurs ils n'ont pas l'audace
d'aller au bout il reste à dire oui mais
non ils sont amoureux de leurs idées ils
sont amoureux de leur projet en fait ils
n'ont pas envie de sortir leur zone ils
n'ont pas envie de se rendre compte que
leur projet n'a pas de valeur alors
toute leur vie diront oui mais moi j'ai
eu l'idée de facebook en même temps que
facebook oui mais moi j'ai eu tes à
l'idée oui mais moi depuis dix ans je
veux faire ça fait le sait de l'audace
qu'il vous faut du culot et pour finir
j'aimerais bien prendre l'exemple de ce
magnifique tapis quand je suis arrivé on
m'a dit magnifique 1 vous le voyez pas
très bien mais d'un rouge totalement
qualitatif
on m'a dit grégoire il faut rester sur
le tapis ouais ouais ouais ok j'ai
compris j'ai parlera de sortir
conscience du hacker l'enfant en moins a
dit pourquoi étape numéro 2 l'essence de
la règle si vous sortez de ce tapis vous
sortez des caméras
du coup vous ne pouvez ne pas être sur
youtube impact terrible un os qu à mon
avis cette vidéo 250-300 vue minimum si
vous sortez du tapis vous êtes hors des
cadres impact vous pouvez ne pas être
sur youtube impact positif
vous pouvez marquer les esprits qu'est
ce que vous dit le hacker le hacker vous
dit au lieu de manger des insectes à la
pause allez voir la régie et la régie
m'a dit mais comment est-ce que je
saurai que doit faire un plan large pour
pas que tu sortes de la vidéo je le dis
mais j'en parlerai est donc là jeudi la
régie active le plan numéro trois et on
en arrive à la dernière étape
mesdames et messieurs les tables qui
fait que vous pourrez devenir acteur de
votre vie de l'audience
[Applaudissements]